اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل 24 ضابطا
وجنديا في المعارك الضاريه في قطاع غزه
خلال الساعات ال 24 الماضيه وقال الجيش ان
مسلحين فلسطينيين اطلقوا قذائف ار بي جي
نحو مبنيين منفصلين في مخيم المغازي وسط
قطاع غزه كان بداخلهما جنود من كتيبه
الهندسه يعملون في مهمه تفجيريه وبحوزتهم
مواد متفجره ما ادى الى انفجار المبنيين
واحداث دمار كبير ومقتل 21 ضابطا وجنديا
في الاثناء تشهد مختلف مناطق قطاع غزه
معارك ضاريه بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه الى تل ابيب
مع الياس كرام مراسل الجزيره الياس تبعنا
قبل قليل بيان مشترك لجانس ونتنياهو وجانت
ما الذي نفهمه من التصريحات ربطا بالخسائر
الكبيره التي مني بها الجيش الاسرائيلي
البارحه
هم ارادوا ان يعبروا اولا وقبل كل شيء
محمد عن الوحده الوطنيه وحده الحال وهذا
ما يحاولون بثه ربما من رسائل الى المجتمع
الاسرائيلي بعد هذه الكارثه كما وصفوها
كان هنالك اجماع بين الثلاثه على التاكيد
على ان ما حصل هو كارثه هو ضرو ضربه قويه
هي ضربه مؤلمه وصعبه بالنسبه لاسرائيل
وبالنسبه للجيش الاسرائيلي والعنوان
الابرز في هذه الكلمه الثلاثيه التي
ارادوا ان يعبروا فيها عن وحده الصف
والحال هو التاكيد على ان هذه الضربه لن
تثني اسرائيل عن مواصله حربها وعن مواصله
قتالها في قطاع غزه حتى تحقيق اهداف هذه
الحرب وهذا هو ربما العنوان الابرز في هذه
الرساله الثلاثيه المشتركه التي اختار
الثلاثي الذي يدير الحرب في مجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي ايه بثها والخروج بها بشكل
مشترك وعلني امام المجتمع الاسرائيلي الذي
اصيب حقيقه في مقتل ازاء هذا العدد الكبير
من الجنود والضباط الذين قتلوا في هذه ال
العمليه كانت هنالك محاوله بطبيعه الحال
لمواساه المجتمع الاسرائيلي كمجتمع لان
هذه ضربه قويه وتؤثر على معنويات المجتمع
الاسرائيلي وايضا محاوله من جانب الثلاثي
لاحتضان العائلات التي فقدت الجنود
والضباط في هذه العمليه وكما قلت التاكيد
على وحده الحال والمصير كان لافتا بان
الوزير بيني جانس عضو مجلس الحرب كان يشدد
على مساله ان الجنود والضباط الذين قتلوا
هم من جنود الاحتياط في الجيش الاسرائيلي
وانهم يعبرون ايضا عن شرائح المجتمع
الاسرائيلي
برمتها وهو كان هنا يلمح حقيقه الى ان
هؤلاء الجنود من الاحتياط هم ربما عناد
الجيش الاسرائيلي وهم ايه القوه الاساسيه
في الجيش الاسرائيلي الذين يخضون هذا
القتال وهذه المعارك وكان بيني جانس كان
يريد ان يلمح الى ما كان في الشهور
الماضيه يلمح اليه اكثر من مسؤول سياسي
تحديدا في المعارضه الاسرائيليه عندما
كانوا يحذرون بنيامين نتنياهو ويقولون بان
الانقلاب القضائي الذي كان يحاول القيام
به على السلطه القضائيه في اسرائيل سوف
تمس قدره الجيش الاسرائيلي ولحمته وقوته و
تحديدا الجنود في صفوف الاحتياط الذين
كانوا ربما عماد الاحتجاجات الشعبيه التي
خرجت للاحتجاج على هذا
الانقلاب القضائي الذي كان يحاول بنيمين
نتنياهو وحكومته اليمينيه المتطرفه احداثه
في القضاء الاسرائيلي الياس ما تاثير هذه
الخسائر الكبيره على الراي العام في
الشارع
الاسرائيلي هو تاثيرها لا شك بانه كبير
على مستوى المعنويات معنويات الجيش
الاسرائيلي من ناحيه ومعنويات المجتمع
الاسرائيلي من ناحيه اخرى لكن هل له اثر
عملي من ناحيه خروج المجتمع الاسرائيلي
باعداد كبيره للتظاهر ضد الحكومه
الاسرائيليه من اجل وقف الحرب حتى الان
بالامكان القول لا لا يوجد لها تاثير كبير
هي مؤلمه حقيقه على مستوى الشخصي للقيادات
السياسيه والعسكريه مؤلمه بالنسبه للمجتمع
الاسرائيلي يصفونها بالكارثي
بالكارثي لكنها حتى هذه الساعه لا تحرك
الشعب المجتمع الاسرائيلي لا تحرك
الاسرائيليين باعداد كبيره من اجل الخروج
للتظاهر ضد الحكومه الاسرائيليه من اجل
وقف هذه الحرب وهذه حقيقه ثابته وواضحه
لكن هنالك بطبيعه الحال مجموعات صغيره ممن
يسمح لهم حتى بالتفوق والتعبير عن معارضه
الحرب يخرجون باعداد قليله بالمئات يعبرون
ربما عن الجناح اليساري في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي الذي يخرج للمجتمع الاسرا يخرج
الى الشارع يعبر عن موقفه ضد الحرب لكن
الاعداد تبقى قليله ولا تعبر حقيقه ربما
عن موقف حتى كل اليسار الاسرائيلي لان
الشرطه الاسرائيليه التي يقودها الوزير
المتطرف ايتمار بنفير لا تسمح حتى لهذه
الاصوات ان تخرج الى الشارع الاسرائيلي
وتتظاهر ضد الحكومه الاسرائيليه وترفع
صوتها ضد استمرار الحرب m